while the film did more than double its
modest budget Sky High didn't crack $100
million worldwide that left Hollywood
cool on the idea of a sequel and since
then the cast and crew have gone on to
have bigger more prosperous careers Kurt
Russell has made a Resurgence largely
thanks to his role in Quinton
Tarantino's the hateful eight while Mary
Elizabeth Winstead became a star thanks
to 2010's Scott Pilgrim versus the world
on television Daniel Panabaker became a
different superhero on the CWS The Flash
while Nicholas Brun garnered a pair of
Emmy nominations thanks to his role in
the HBO drama succession getting the
gang back together may not be such an
easy feat but there have been plenty of
rumors over the years implying that such
an event could still happen